[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight Congress is still trying
to come to an agreement on daca that's
President Obama's program that gives
work permits to illegal immigrants who
arrived here as minors the tone of the
debate over this has changed quite a bit
in the last few days
thanks holy - president Trump's now
famous common suggesting that some
countries are not as appealing as other
countries and may in fact not produce
equally desirable immigrants well
America's elites have recoiled in shock
and horror and rage how dare he say
something like that and so from
Hollywood to Silicon Valley to MSNBC a
new consensus has formed which of course
the rest of us are now required to
believe so get a pen it's this every
other country is great especially the
poor and disorganized ones and the
immigrants those countries sent here are
uniformly more impressive than you are
every single one of them they fight more
wars they pay more taxes they start more
companies than your kids ever will so
shut up with your doubts or inconvenient
questions otherwise we will fire you so
that's where our moral betters on cable
news are telling us vehemently the
question is do they really believe that
do they really think that all standards
are arbitrary and racist and that
everyone from everywhere is exactly the
same level of Awesome well for an answer
ignore what they say take instead a
close look at how they live do our
elites and their own children to
colleges with universal admittance
policies where everybody gets it of
course they don't their kids go to
Harvard and Stanford and Yale those are
the most respected universities in the
world precisely because they're the most
selective ones
Harvard's acceptance rate is just a hair
above 5% they brag about how many high
school valedictorians they reject now
Harvard has countless professors who
support open borders and fret about
white privilege yet how many admissions
officers do they have who will admit
poorly educated Haitians who can't speak
English
let's see none not a single one Harvard
is famous and admired because it's
selective in other words because it
discriminates on the basis of
achievement and ability
if Harvard chose its students the way
America chooses its immigrants are
elites wouldn't send their kids there
the cachet would be gone along with the
quality the same of course goes for
corporate America does Facebook hired by
a diversity lottery come on would google
apply temporary protected status to its
own workforce hiring and keeping
thousands of people with no relevant
skills simply because they're from
impoverished backgrounds another dumb
question the people who run Google in
Facebook care about their companies in
the same way that people run Harvard
care about their school the one thing
none of them care about is America which
is why they're demanding standards for
our country they would never apply to
themselves it is sickening and
hypocritical and we've had enough of it
going forward we're gonna push this
country's elites to live by the
standards they espouse if America must
give citizenship to 11 million
undocumented immigrants Harvard ought to
give free tuition to 1,100 undocumented
students if it's okay to sneak into your
city illegally and use the public
services why is it wrong to live in a
dorm at Princeton without being enrolled
Jeff Bezos thinks it's immoral to send
dreamers back to their own countries
okay why shouldn't Bezos give a few
thousand of them high paying corporate
jobs at Amazon well of course he should
immediately the truth is our ruling
class supports our current immigration
policy because for them it's all upside
they're not standing in line in crowded
emergency rooms or sending their kids to
chaotic public schools or competing for
jobs with people who will work for less
than they will for them open borders
mean cheaper labor and bountiful
household help and above all the sense
that unlike you they're good people they
care they're not bigots like those
voters in Kentucky and Ohio what a
ruler's need is a strong dose of reality
a sense of what their policies mean for
everybody else so let's give them that
you can send your ideas to us on Twitter
you can do that by sending her tweet two
at Tucker Carlson we're interested in
what you think in the meantime we're
joined tonight by Cesar Vargas he's both
an illegal immigrant and an attorney in
New York mr. Vargas thanks for coming
out Tucker happy new year happy new year
so it's a pretty simple calculation
why not treat America like you're really
cared about it our policymakers treat it
with maybe half the care that Harvard
treats its school with and say we're
gonna try and figure out which
immigrants are gonna be the most
successful sound about race but it is
about the massive amount of data we have
on how people do once they get here and
people are more likely to succeed will
get preference and those were less
likely to succeed won't what's wrong
with that well two very important points
the first point is that the United
States is not a company the United
States is not a school it's a nation
second point we want to make sure that
we scrutinize every person coming here
into the country we want to make sure
that they don't have any terrorist
background we want to make sure they are
they don't have a violent criminal
record no one disputes that but let's
get disappointing very important that
the United Nation was created mainly in
the Declaration of Independence because
the King restricted immigration because
the King of England said States colonies
you can no longer bring people from
other country and what happened American
Revolution okay but let's just back up a
little bit you said that the two
standards we need to apply are people
aren't terrorists and they don't have a
criminal record would you apply those
standards in your own life to anything
I'm going to hire this person I'll let
him into my school I'll marry this
person just as long as this person
doesn't have a terror background or a
criminal record
shouldn't we aim a little bit higher
than that if we really cared about the
country of course we want to have
standards but at the same time what made
this great nation is what we've seen the
Statue of Liberty give me your poor your
huddled masses and look your ancestors
came here when they were poor many
ancestors of our founding fathers came
here when the report and now look at you
Tucker you're a successful father of
missile here you're kind of missing it
and this is gonna light for them we're
not in the eighteenth century now and if
you really care about the country you
think deeply about what's gonna make it
better and safer and more prosperous
happier more cohesive you don't adopt a
based approach that says there's an
inscription on the bottom of a statue in
New York Harbor let's just roll with
that and hope for the best
you don't do that so why wouldn't you
say for example we nas give you I'll
throw us that out here you tell me if
you think it's relevant so the Science
Talent Search competition tries to
identify kids who are good at science
which is like a pretty good measure it's
tested students in America 14 of the top
40 had Indian immigrant parents so that
would suggest well gee whiz that and a
lot of other markers suggested the
Indians do pretty well what did
encourage a lot more Indian immigration
why would that be bad what we wanted we
want to make sure that we attract the
best obviously but we want to attract
people who have a belief of what it
means to be American someone who
believed that if they come here work
hard that is what makes this nation
great it doesn't mean about people hey
give me your scientist give me your
engineers it says if you work hard you
can be an American we can roll with that
too so we're not gonna measure success
or intelligence or anything like that
just a hard work so then you wouldn't be
against saying if you're here as an
immigrant you take no public benefit of
any kind you can't go to an emergency
room for health care you can't I don't
know use emergency Medicaid for your
health care you can't take any kind of
program at all right because why would
we bring people here and then give them
free stuff would you before that well I
am for no taxation without
representation they should be able to
get protection they should be able to
get health care if they're paying for
their own doctor if they're paying for
their own security I think that's what
it would it be fair would it be fair for
the people who own this country which is
its voters and citizens to say we're
gonna do just a really simple
cost-benefit analysis in every immigrant
are you paying in more than you're
taking out in services how about that
and if you're not you have to leave well
think of that in 2016 undocumented
immigrants immigrants contribute two
trillion dollars so they generalisations
know sort of how about in each specific
case we say if you're an immigrant here
really simple prove that you're
producing more than you consume if you
think that's the point that's the
criterion we're gonna use would you be
for applying that standard
and for the American people I'm for
Republicans Democrats coming together
you're not I want to create standards
that work for everyone I want to stand
there how about citizen work for Marren
it's not for everybody because America
doesn't exist to help the populations of
other countries it exists the government
exists for one reason
let's look out for its own people its
voters it's a democracy as you may know
so why wouldn't the American people have
a right to say we're only admitting
people who can demonstrate they make
this country better not in some general
sense so they're all valedictorians war
heroes but like in a very specific
mathematical sense what would be wrong
with that because this nation is such a
great place because we have allowed the
poor that Matt the people who are hungry
back there your ancestors were poor your
ancestors of your viewers you don't know
which of this country to be listen for
me I want to make sure that I'm here as
an attorney representing veterans I'm
representing military family you're
capable ask you a really simple question
if more immigration always makes the
country richer then why does the state
with the most immigration which is
California keep getting poorer it now is
more poverty than any state one out of
five Californians is poor if immigration
makes us richer why is California
getting poor what's the answer to that I
wonder well I would just say that
California has the surplus of more than
ten billion dollars into their state
economy why because many factors but
because it's a welcoming state so
California's gotten poorer one in five
Californians is poor that was not the
case when I grew up in California it has
the most immigration so if immigration
always makes us more prosperous why is
the opposite happening in California is
a very simple question
but I think there is many factors I
don't think he says has to do with
immigration I think has to do the fact
that we need to manage budgets right and
I think Republicans and Democrats would
agree on that
so immigrants is not it's not nothing to
do with it even though powerfully is now
poorer than Mississippi immigration
which is the main thing that separates
California from Mississippi has no role
in that because
do you have data on that or you just
kind of don't want to admit it like
everyone else well I also don't think
that we have data to blame immigrants
for every problem of the world no no
we're giving them credit for every
success we're saying this country is
rich because of immigrants here's a
state with the most immigrants why is it
the poorest state I mean am I being
crazy I think it's a fair question well
I also say that California has a surplus
right now the economy is doing very well
and so I could always also say the
immigrants are a Latinas doing great
because of immigrants but there's many
factors into play but I would just say
that at the end of the day having an
economy what's superb is why don't we
stop the magical thinking and get real
because things are changing really fast
in this country and we care about our
country everyone see the best it can be
and the point is not to make other
countries happy it's to protect our
people so I think I hope you'll give us
a pass on trying to think that through
an irrational one that's work together
on this all right Cesar thanks for
joining thank you so much good